by the economic secretary to the
Treasury Stephen Barclay so mr. Barclays
good evening to you I mean it was really
striking at the CBI today the lukewarm
reception Teresa may receive you in
danger of losing the business vote we
have extensive engagement with business
throughout the summer and leading into
the autumn there's been a whole series
of roundtables with industry leaders
business forums listening to the voice
of industry and that was very much
reflected in the Florence speech that
the prime minister gave and hinault
remarks today and if you look at the
feedback to the flowing speech business
very much felt that they had been
listened to their message had been heard
and their desire for clarity from the
government had been given but we also
heard from Paul Drexler the CBI
president he actually said on stage
that's the the negotiations were over
brexit of becoming like a soap opera I
mean there was no new detail from the PM
today on the transitional arrangement no
clarity whatsoever but the Florence
speech move things forward obviously
there's both sides that need to come to
the table and be imaginative in response
to the challenge on brexit
but the government has set out that we
want an ambitious free-trade agreement
covering goods and services and has very
much listened to the voice of business
in seeking a transition deal and seeking
for as much certainty as soon as
possible and that's been a key ask as
financial services minister from the
industries i've spoken to and it's been
a key ask of the chancellor and that
message from business has been listened
to it's been heard and is very much our
approach so when do you think we might
get some more detail on the timing of a
transition agreement well obviously
that's in part linked to the response
for the European Union we've got the
December council which will be a key
point in this but we're very sited on
the fact that industry wants as much
certainty as soon as possible
contingency plans around quarter one in
particular as the CBI themselves said
today will be at a key point and so it's
in both sides interest it's not an EU
27s interests to have fragmentation
costs in areas like financial services
or further to be greater financial
instability as a result of areas such as
on contact continuity on data protection
and those sort of issues so it's in both
sides interest to have a transition deal
agreed as soon as possible
and that's what business wants it's what
the UK government wants and it's what
we're discussing with the European
Union I just wonder what you're made of
ana super you'll colleague Anna sue
Brees comments on Twitter today where
she said by aligning yourselves with har
brexit by making yourselves the party of
hard brexit the conservatives are
actually allowing the most left-wing
labour party of all time to present
itself as more pro-business well there's
a range of views on Twitter at any point
but the point is that business want to
transition deal they wants as much
certainty as possible on that and that's
very much Ana's view that there should
be a transition deal and it's the
government's views so so actually we're
in line on that point where business arm
in terms of the opposition is they have
no idea what their actual brick state
policy is it constantly is changing
whether it's kir storm of other members
of the labor front bench you get a very
different story one week to the next
the bottom line is we need a transition
deal as soon as possible
that is what both Anna Suber II and the
government have called for all right
Steven Bharti we gotta leave it there
thanks for joining me